in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for April 25 on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle and Evangelist Mark.
On the 25th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostle and Evangelist Mark.
The Holy and glorious Apostle Mark, who was also called John, was the son of a devout woman
in Jerusalem, named Mary, who offered her house to the Apostles disciples when they met for prayer.
St. Peter went there often and had an affection for the young Mark,
whom he instructed in the faith and baptized, looking on him as his son. He was also a cousin of
the Holy Apostle Barnabas, who took Mark with him when he left for Antioch, together with St. Paul.
During these missionary journeys, Mark humbly helped the two preachers, seeing to their material
needs and drinking in their teaching. Arriving in Perga in Pamphilia, Mark was overcome with fear
in the face of the difficulties of the mission and left Paul in Barnabas returning to Jerusalem.
St. Paul appears to have been hurt by this parting, and when they met again in Antioch,
he refused to take him with him, one who departed from them, from Pamphilia, and went not with them
to the work. The discussion became heated, and Barnabas decided to sail for Cyprus with Mark,
while Paul left with Silas to evangelize Syria and Selissia.
Ten years later, we find Saint Mark in Rome, together with Aristarchus and Jesus' justice,
to be of assistance to Paul in his captivity. He departed thence with a blessing of the great
Apostle to visit the Christians of Colossae. During Paul's second captivity, he wrote to Timothy,
suggesting that he bring Mark with him, for he is profitable to me, for the ministry.
It was also around the year 65 that Mark rejoined Saint Peter in Rome, at the moment at which the
two great Apostles were about to endure their martyrdom. The brilliance of Saint Peter's teaching
had so shown in the spirits of the newly converted in Rome that they begged Mark to set his divine
doctrine down. This being confirmed by divine revelation, and with Peter's agreement, he set
to work, and wrote, in a short, simple, popular, and lively way, a summary of the Savior's works and
words, according to the teaching of the chief of the Apostles. Without preoccupying himself with
the literary presentation, or with answering all the questions that the faithful might ask,
he wrote, all that is profitable for salvation, and the knowledge of the Son of God made man,
and nothing more. Once this work was completed, Saint Peter sent him to Egypt to take the good news
there. During the voyage, the ship encountered a great storm, which Mark calmed by his prayers,
and he was able to make landfall on the island of Pitusa, across from Selissia, where he was received
by an eminent citizen called Basus. He had been converted by Saint Peter, and due to his support,
Mark was able to convert the majority of the inhabitants of the island. When he disembarked in
Alexandria, Mark's sandal, worn by the walking he had done, was worn out, and he gave it to a
cobbler called Anianos to mend. He, struck by the brilliance that radiated from the Apostles' face,
let his needle fall and pricked his finger, crying out, only one God. St. Mark healed the wound,
and made use of the occasion to instruct him in the truth of the one God become man for our salvation.
Anianos listened attentively to these words of life, and after having had all his household baptized,
forsook his profession, and all attachment to the world to become the Apostles' closest collaborator.
In this immense city, the metropolis of paganism and Hellenic culture, the Apostles' words in their
simplicity and freedom, from all futile rhetorical flourishes, resounded like thunder, and his miracles
confirmed the psalmist prophecy. The Lord giveeth speech to those who proclaim the good news,
with great power. In the name of Jesus, the light of the world, he gave sight to a blind man.
They immediately brought him to the infirm and possessed, for him to lay hands on them,
beholding the healings wrought by the power of God, nearly 300 pagans in one day,
asked to receive holy baptism. As Christ himself had done, Mark also restored to life the son of a widow,
who had thrown herself at his feet in tears, and the crowd, seeing the young man restored,
cried out, there is but one God, the Christ whom Mark preaches.
The evangelical seed began to germinate, Mark organized first liturgical practices in the
Egyptian church, and consecrated Anianos as bishop of Alexandria, with three priests to a system,
Melius, Sabinos, and Carthon, seven deacons, and eleven other clergy in lesser orders.
He then continued his mission westwards. From Alexandria, he went to Mendesium, and there freed
a blind child from the demon. The child's overjoyed parents offered him a large sum of money,
but Mark refused it, saying that the grace of God cannot be exchanged for money, and recommended to
them that they give it in alms. A considerable number of pagans, being converted after this miracle,
Mark founded a church in the city, and consecrated a bishop, priests, and deacons, then continued his
journey to Cyrene, in Penthapolis, where he delivered a number of pagans from the darkness of idolatry.
He then went to preach the gospel in Libya. As soon as he arrived in the capital,
the daughter of Menodorus, the Philarchus, who had been tormented by a demon since her childhood,
experienced an acute crisis which led to her death, but the Apostle's prayer revived her,
and brought about a great number of conversions. Saint Mark went thence to Marmarica,
spreading the light of the gospel on the way. One night, the Lord appeared to him in a vision,
and ordered him to return to Alexandria, and there accomplish his mission. In spite of the prayers
and supplications of the newly converted, who wanted to keep the Apostle, their father and savior,
the call was confirmed by a second vision, telling him that he must set the seal on his mission
with the glory of martyrdom. He left by ship for Alexandria, where he was delighted by the progress of
evangelization in the two years of his absence. The pagans and the Jews, however, were unable to bear
the success achieved by Christ's disciple, and grinding their teeth sought an opportunity to do
away with him. One year, when the celebration of Easter coincided with the feast of the God's
set-upies, a feast that the inhabitants of Alexandria were accustomed to celebrating with unspeakable
orgies, they fell on the saint while he was celebrating the divine liturgy, and dragged him to
the amphitheater before the governor, accusing him of practicing magic. The Apostle replied calmly
to these hateful accusations, and expressed in a few words, as was his custom, the sublime doctrine
of salvation. Disconcerted and being unable to make any reply to his arguments, the governor turned
to the crowd, asking what should be done with Mark. Some cried out, but he be burned in front of the
temple of set-upies, while others called for his stoning. Finally, at the magistrate's order,
he was stretched spread-eagled on the ground and cruelly flogged. Then the people, laying hold of the
saint's half-dead body, tied a rope to its feet, and dragged it round the city's roads all day.
Its blood sprinkling the rocks and the earth. When evening came, he was shut in prison,
where around midnight an angel appeared to him and comforted him.
On the morning of April 4, the executioners tied him to a rope and dragged him, as on the previous day,
to a high cliff by the sea, called Bukolia, now abukure, where the saint found death.
He was 57 years old. The pagans wanted to burn his body, but a violent storm put them to flight,
and allowed the Christians to recover it and bury it in a crevice in the rock.
They later built a church over the Apostles' tomb at Bukolia, which became the high spot of
devotion for the Christians of Alexandria. In the 9th century, the saint's body was taken to Venice,
and placed in the famous Basilica that bears his name. Through the prayers of our holy fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.